we start with the latest efforts to
defuse growing tensions between russia
and ukraine ukraine's president vladimir
celenski is calling for calm after
speaking with u.s president biden he
said there has been no further
escalation with russia at the moment and
he is asking allies to dial down talk of
war
earlier russian president putin whose
country has masked tens of thousands of
troops near ukraine's border accused
nato and the u.s of ignoring russia's
security concerns nato says it is
prepared to put more troops in eastern
europe after washington warned ukraine
to be on alert for an invasion
scanning the landscape on this ukrainian
border city
troops try to gauge moscow's next move
one soldier believes an attack here in
luhansk is unlikely
our navy is not strong enough to
withstand heavy attack
the coastline could be easily captured
that's my opinion
everybody thinks about invasion through
haki for donbass but that's the wrong
point of view
if they attack they will do it from the
sea
in the black sea russia's navy carries
out drills on friday
still the kremlin says it wants a
peaceful resolution
if it's up to us the russian federation
there will be no war
we don't want war but we will not allow
interest to be violated
and we will not allow our interests to
be ignored either
it's hoped a diplomatic offensive will
de-escalate tensions high-stakes talks
with various players are giving hope
that a war in eastern europe can be
averted
for those stuck in the middle
life is on
we hold hope russia takes us for good
because it has to stop at some point
it's been what
eight years of conflict
as diplomatic efforts advance the u.s is
still warning ukraine to prepare for a
russian invasion
for more on the story we can speak now
to radoswafski who played a key role in
formulating the eu's response to russia
when he served as polish foreign
minister during the ukraine crisis in
2014 and mr cerkorski is now part of the
conservative bloc in the european
parliament welcome to dw and good
evening to you
if we look at what ukraine's president
has been saying today he is essentially
saying that the west and journalists in
particular are playing up this panic
then it's time to dial down uh the
tensions now the u.s says a russian
attack is distinctly possible next month
what do you think moscow is planning
well president zielenski needs to keep
his economy his the finances of ukraine
uh stable so he needs to reassure people
but we know from satellite imagery that
over a hundred thousand troops
uh are massed uh uh all around ukraine
ukraine is surrounded on three sides by
russia
um that this has been exercised before
and that russia is making demands
president putin regards ukraine as a
temporary
artificial stage and he's made it very
plain repeatedly i was at the nato
summit in bucharest in 2008
when he spoke about it quite openly
and he last july he published a
manifesto for the subjugation or
dismembering
of ukraine so this is very serious oh so
russia has of course on the record
denied any plans to invade ukraine but
why do you think we're seeing this troop
build up now what prompted it is it do
you think as some analysts have
suggested that
vladimir putin is taking advantage of a
time where europe is distracted
well of course
you know that the russians lied about
not wanting to take over crimea either
and then they lied again about donbass
and they lied about the malaysian
airliner
and so on uh so yes i mean aggressors
lie nothing new about that um
but why do they have a hundred thousand
troops massed
uh ukraine is a democracy a a member of
the u.n in good standing uh a member of
the osce uh ukraine has russian security
guarantees
uh budapest memorandum of 1994 under
which ukraine gave up what was then the
third largest nuclear arsenal in return
for these guarantees which which russia
has already broken well i have to ask
you about what russia says here because
it actually says that the u.s and nato
are the aggressors here not russia
itself by expanding its eastward
presence by
stationing troops and sending arms to
eastern member states so what's your
response to that
well at the nato summit i've already
mentioned germany
vetoed uh giving ukraine a membership
action plan and nothing has happened
about that since then except that russia
has invaded georgia russia has taken
over crimea russia has invaded donbass
russia has installed iskandar
nuclear-tipped missiles with arranged to
reach you in berlin and russia has shut
down that malaysian airliner with dutch
citizens on it so actually it should be
us that should be asking russia for
security guarantees i have to ask you mr
shkorsky you actually as we mentioned at
the beginning worked hard to bring
ukraine closer to the european union
were you the polish foreign minister
how did you expect russia to respond to
that
why should russia respond to it at all
countries have the right to choose
which trade which customs areas they
belong to
we were negotiating a similar
arrangement with russia herself
it's none of russia's business ukraine
is an independent country
in the face of what you say is very
clear aggression here from russia what
do you think the european union should
be doing now
well the decisions to supply defensive
equipment are national decisions but if
you are against war you should be
helping ukraine defend itself because
that's what deters president putin
and we should be
conducting our foreign policy in common
as we pledged ourselves to do in the
lisbon treaty but unfortunately some of
the biggest member states are
freelancing to not to
not have very good effect i hear what
you're saying so i'll ask you directly
should germany be sending defensive
weapons to ukraine
of course
you know a u.n member in good standing
is being threatened with dismemberment
by by an aggressive neighbor i remember
his
you know
germany um wreaked a huge destruction uh
to ukraine mainly in belarus not russia
during the second world war you have a
special duty to preserve the peace in
europe
vader schwab
a former polish foreign minister joining
us here on our program thank you so much
so much for sharing your insights with
us today
my pleasure
with the focus uh on ukraine at the
moment germany and its ties with russia
are also in the spotlight and we can
bring in our political correspondent
thomas sparrow for the latest on that hi
thomas a lot of questions are being
asked here in germany about what the
country is willing to put on the table
so is germany prepared to suffer
economic consequences to send a message
to russia
it is certainly preparing itself to
suffer economic consequences and in fact
germany's foreign minister alina berbock
stressed precisely that very recently
when she met u.s secretary of state
anthony blinken saying that any
aggression from russia will be met with
strong consequences from the west even
if that means also economic consequences
at home in particular what everyone is
talking about is the north stream two
pipeliner pipeline which has already
been built under the baltic sea joining
russia and germany which is waiting for
regulatory approval and which is being
strongly criticized by countries like
the united states or some of germany's
allies in the european union including
for example
poland whereas german officials in the
current government but also in previous
governments have stressed that nordstrom
2 is mostly an economic project the us
and these european countries believe
that it is putting germany at risk
making europe vulnerable and giving too
much power to russia
so that's why in essence nordstrom 2 is
becoming a very important and also very
controversial part of this whole
equation around the us russia ukraine
conflict and so on and thomas i want to
ask you about another part of the debate
here in germany which is whether to send
arms to ukraine why is it that germany
is still refusing to send weapons
and this is one issue sumi where germany
differs from other countries whereas the
us or the uk have sent defensive weapons
to ukraine germany has refused to do so
they did send for example 5 000 helmets
to ukraine but they are not willing to
send defensive weapons essentially
because they believe
that that could make tensions even
higher and that could make the prospect
of a negotiated solution even more
difficult to achieve and it's important
to stress that germany alongside other
countries like france is really hoping
for a negotiated solution to all of this
for example by reviving the so-called
normandy format talks france germany
russia and ukraine so germany's hope is
essentially put on a diplomatic solution
to the crisis and not in sending
defensive weapons to ukraine
our political correspondent thomas
sparrow thanks so much for your analysis
you